how can a writer develop characters
using the three wells of screenwriting
okay that's it's kind of super easy it's
one of the easiest ways to talk about a
chapter in the book on writing
characters from using the three wells
and just to give you an idea if you have
a character and they can be a very minor
character or a major character but I'll
just use the minor character for an
excellent for an example because it can
show you how kind of powerful the wells
can be if we're example you've got a
character that's walking into a store
and they have some meeting with the
store clerk you know as a clerk at the
clerk at the store and they're doing
something and they have some dialogue
between them so this is a minor
character the store clerk is some minor
character who you could just write as
store clerk one but if you want to kind
of use the three Wells to maybe pump up
that character but you can look at your
external source as well and make a list
of characters from movies that you like
they could be absolutely random
characters but then they should be in a
way just I like this character I like
this character I like you know the guy
from the shining I like I don't know
it's just anyone I like okay the Michael
Corleone you from The Godfather
think of all the good movies now for
some reason whatever I watched recently
I like the Spider Man's best buddy in
spider-man he's funny and you make a
list of all the movies characters from
other movies you've seen and then you
take your store your store clerk and you
say
could he be spider-man's buddy from that
other maybe he could be spider-man's
buddy from the other movie and suddenly
your imagination well he's kind of
lighting up because you're making a
collision of two things and suddenly
you've got this okay what happens if he
was spider-man's buddy from the other
man in the clock sudden he has a
character's got glasses he's a bit
chubby and he's like really funny and
maybe he's like you know wearing a maybe
he's maybe what you buy from him he said
something about linked up to movies or
comic books and now you've got a
character certainly just from from doing
that so that's a it's almost like a like
a Rolodex you flipping through all these
characters that exist before I'm putting
them in kind of minor parts of your
movie you can do it with a major
character but then you need to take
elements from different characters and
put them together and so you take you
know the sort of I don't know the anger
of one character mix with the daddy
issues with another character mixed with
something from and then you can create
sort of composite characters using other
movies it can be really fun
and can be really effective and can
spark of your imagination well this is
how you do it you you kind of collide
ideas together and in that collision of
store clerk and spider-mans buddy your
imagination is just suddenly gone off
and he's suddenly a much clearer
character by the way when you write that
into your script when you read the
script the character deeps of the page
because suddenly your minor characters
have become really really interesting
the other really fun thing is to go into
your memory wall and go clerks without
experience okay that could be one thing
you could do or you could say I'm sure
by the way this is what it looks like
tapping into the memory what always
takes a bit longer because you have to
kind of look into your own life and it's
like slows down a bit and you like okay
so there's this guy Kevin yeah he's a
buddy of mine he's got his hair shaved
on the side he's got tattoos all over
him and he's kind of like quite a fun
guys a bit strange got an interesting
way of talking what if he was the clerk
oh yeah that could work well maybe it
won't work at all maybe cuz some of the
characters but but what you can access
in your memory well it's absolutely
unique characters that no one's seen
before and then suddenly they're the
store clerk and then suddenly all your
stock leaps off the page I actually had
this experience in a story that I wrote
I think I talked about it in the book
where I had a manager in a music store
so one of my characters had a she made
her own songs and she was trying to get
her songs on she she would put them onto
like a DV disc like a CD and try and
sell it to the store but the store clerk
the idea was that she's not gonna get
that salt because the store clerks just
like it's against company company policy
and the store clerk I just chose this
random guard from my life totally
tattooed everywhere piercings everywhere
long hair slightly effeminate I think he
might go buy another gender at the
moment it I'm not sure but he or she is
the store clerk now in the in the movie
and suddenly the character was really
alive and he was interesting and my
character was trying to sell her songs
had a baby and she was holding the baby
and at some point she passes it to the
store clerk man holding this baby like
it's against company policy and it's
like is it does he mean holding the baby
or does he mean the CD and suddenly
there was like a whole into action so
going from the memory wall in your minor
character
really pump it up but also I think in
the major characters so when you
creating character is is a real art form
actually and then you know people spend
a lot of time you trying to watch your
backstory of your character what's the
history of a character and there's
there's some something about being able
to empathize with your characters
sometimes you have to draw from your own
experiences around something similar to
what that characters gone through and
then suddenly it becomes really real for
you and then suddenly starts resonating
for you and that character matters to
you and then you write from that
position so that's a summary of how you
can beef up characters using the three
wells yeah there's a whole chapter on it
so you'd have to to get into it might
take a while but yeah those those little
samples I mean I promise you you just go
through your script take all your minor
characters use the externals of all your
memory well and your script will
suddenly have a lot more life and when
people read it they'll go oh wow that
character leaps off the page what's he
done different well not much she's just
attached something to them so they yeah
so they real I guess it's about trying
to create something that is a real space
for the reader I like that I like that
clerk analogy because you could think to
ones in movies but then you can also
think to ones let you experience that
you first maybe didn't think about or
ones that really stood out whether they
were really nice or thank you one time I
had someone accused me of stealing
something and you accused me right at
the register why and I said oh you
didn't see the receipt for the thing in
the bag from the other store that I went
to and then it was like this awkward
even talking about awkward moment story
yeah and it was great because then I
can't want to keep seeing him but I knew
in the back of my mind and he knew and I
didn't say anything I wasn't gonna call
him out or yeah it's amazing
but I that was such a vivid memory or
interacting with a clerk and they've
been great times when joke around
they're they're fun and but but that's
true it seems like such a minor thing
but if you look and then if you look at
back what you've told me now is the
scene that's got subtext amazing
subjects like going back to the store
when you know and he knows and really
there's great subtext there and that's
the stuff that really works and movies
you know so actually a movie that
haven't seen is the farewell which is I
was just going to go see that okay yeah
well that's one maybe
I think it's gonna be really interesting
and I heard the podcast that is based on
because this American laughter the
podcast of the fair basically the
farewell was the podcast many years ago
and she wrote the movie and now directed
it that movie I think is gonna have many
moments of subtext absolute complex
subjects because of the structure of the
movie but also because it's based on a
memory well it's all from a memory well
and so that kind of everyone's trying to
teach how to write subtext it's very
difficult you almost have to either the
characters must be so alive or you have
to draw from life and then you get that
immediately you talk about story and
subtext it's in your one memory that
popped up in your when I mentioned Clerk
you were like yes I've got that already
everybody's got that and yours is unique
if you wrote that scene it would be a
unique story sure that's so funny that
you note on the farewell mm-hmm great
excellent
you